- So what poster did each of you have
on your bedroom wall while growing up?
I'll start here.
- My favorite musician was
Prince who was a genius.
- Oh, very sophisticated 90 oh! My!
Oh my God! This is the poster?
- That is it.
- I have not spent a year
of the last few years
of my life in London and everyday,
I have to at every intersection be like,
oooh!,ooooh!oooh!
- Do they just not paying attention.
- ummh! Well, they're just
coming from the wrong way.
There is competition
- Ooh! come on, stop showing off.
- Yeah kelly your ridiculous,
I love coming on your show, yea
(clapping)
(guitar racketing)
- They seem so naughty
(laughing) (upbeat music)
- I have been a single dad
for five years now and I mean,
single, single, like not
even one date in five years,
but how do I go about having
that conversation where daddy's
on Bumble now? And....
- For what I do, It was bring men around
with my son introduced as a friend.
So there's, you know, he just sees it.
You know, mommy has male friends.
Also kids are very good
at seeing red flags.
Cause my child would say,
mommy, you know he smokes weed.
(laughing)
- Please, please tell me your responses is
So does mommy,
- Oh my God!
- what would you do though
If you got a weird gift
like that in front of your grandma
- In front, did she give it
to me or didn't she is....
- Oh! I missed the question.
- You grandma's gift to you.....
- Wait, your grandma gave this to you?
I totally read it and didn't even ,
I thought you were just opening it.
Get it grandma.
- I know
- That's an awkward question.
We should maybe take out.
- Take out....
- just got it..just like wow
- Your discretion advised
- Yeah am saying
- Kelly discretion is an x
- Yeah I know I discretion it was just
something Clarkson you get
in front of you grandma.
- Triple x
- I totally read it. And didn't
actually...yeah that's crazy
- Batteries included (laughing)
- This is were machine and humanity merge
(sloughing)
- Wait Mali. Can we do
one last question please?
Because there's a war going on
right now between millennials
and Gen Z.
- Okay we are getting into this
- Let's get into this, how do you feel,
when you look at Kelly and myself,
but we'll miss make it about
me. You can dunk on me.
Do you look at us and go, wow,
they are old because I remember being 14.
- Yeah. This conversation with someone
because I'm almost 40. And I was like,
I remember when I was young
and I was like 40 is so old.
- So old, and then when we
get the first credit card
and they go, you, all you have to do
is pay it off by 2018 and go that year's
not real by the year 2032.
Its never going to be 2023.
And you're like, it's
never going to be 2030.
Leah. Your thoughts?
- My thought is, I don't think
if you guys is not young,
I'm trying to.
- We are old......
- Oh! My god!
- So how you got to be honest to me,
like how we're will
Smith's tennis skills like,
oh your eyes, wait.
Don't y'all usually
have to like for films,
have to like really go hardcore,
like in like practice
for what you're doing.
- Oh,
- So y'all did.
- We did, so we did some
very intense tennis training,
but Mr. W ill did not.
And that's mostly because
Richard didn't like the,
he didn't know how to play tennis.
He kind of taught himself
in order to teach Serena and
Venus. Yeah.
It was a lot of fun playing
with him because I feel like it
made us feel like we were
so good because you know.
(Soughing)
- He can't hear that enough.
- Gotta be honest with you
never handed out Nerf balls.
What's happening here?
- So, I was doing it. I
was, I wasn't even going up.
I was just went to go watch
an open mic with my friend and
he signed me up and they called Ms. Pat
coming to the session. I'm like I am.
And so at this night it was a black spot.
They throw ball Nerf balls at
you. If you don't like them,
if they don't like you and
the guy hit me in my forehead,
I didn't even get the joke
out. So you're my ex drug.
Dealer and I'm ready to
fight. So I.... (laughing)
- Wait, wait, you left that
out in your 10 second spill.
- Traffic, a lot of cocaine
back in the night.(laughing)
- The guy even returned
the creature to the nearby.
The nearby who knows if he
is taking the trash out.
We have this reptile rescue.(laughing)
I didn't even see the end.
- But now, I discovered
something that is amazing
and a real thing called slow jogging.
Have you heard of this?
- I mean, I think I do it.
- Okay me too but no, but
wait, its slower than walking.
Like you're literally like I
started and it's so good for
your legs makes you smile the whole time.
It's not stressful.
So I'll be like running
through my neighborhood.
Literally like, I swear to god
but it makes me so happy. Google it.
I'll are sloughing and you
are going to google it.
I asked my husband genuinely
do this. I did I this morning.
- I just genuinely love that
your neighbors were like ,
what's wrong with her( laughing)
- Well later you'll be singing
a song called one more time.
So what's that about?
- Well, will you split
up with the girlfriend?
- Yes. Well, no, but....
- And the sex was good,
- Well I'll put on my imagination hat.
- When you split up with your boyfriend,
and the sex was exceptional,
but that all your going out with for.
- Okay. Yeah.
- And you split up and
you say lets just do it,
well Upstairs one more time.
- Oh, this is a great idea.
- I've never done it myself. Have you?
- liar?
- Honestly I haven't, I've never done it.
I've never done that, no, no
- Just a sec one more...you
know pulling.(laughing)
- I love it that this
angle you can see my sock
and less work pants.(laughing)
- My God! we couldn't
see that at all here.
That is so awseome.i love zoom.
- So wait when speaking
you said you don't like
doing furniture and stuff like that,
- The chain, the chain,
Wiki, Wiki, do you.
- No TJ, Or do you decorate for Christmas?
- Did you just call me a whore?
- So you love to restore houses.
Do you like decorating for Christmas?
You're trying to stay if*****.
The producers in here are
like stick with Christmas.
I got it. I got, I got it
already purchased advertisement.
That is Christmas theme.
So yeah, you talk about,
I love Christmas Christmas at Mayfair.